you told me this great story that I was
hoping you would repeat that involves
Adele I love us I love celebrity gossip
and dish oh I have it you went you went
to a big celebrity party and Ellen
DeGeneres's 60th birthday party oh and
there was a stage for all of Ellen's
friends that were singers and people
would get up throughout the party and
perform and then they kind of hand off
the moment to somebody else you can see
like Melissa Etheridge and Anthony
Kiedis and whoever that's cool and Adele
was at the party and there was a lot of
like hotels here wonder when Adele's
gonna get on stage I heard Adele's
performing next and just and then she
never got up to perform
and so I was just like I'll do it
[Applause]
pink pink was just wrapping up and I was
the level of performer it's study so
pink is just performing she's finishing
up that's what he's finishing up Bruno
Mars is they're all my best friends yeah
team they're called the dig team team
TIG is on stage so pink is wrapping up
and I went up to the stage and I was
like hey I wanted to sing a song and she
was like great you could tell she was so
excited because she knew I did comedy
but she didn't know as a singer and and
she said what song do you want to sing
and I said I wanted to sing Adele's
hello you know she was even more excited
because not only has she found out that
I'm a singer but she just found out that
I am a phenomenal singer yeah you can't
do an Adele song any other way I had to
be incredible incredible right and so
she was she was beside herself and then
I said here's the thing I don't know any
of the words
could you ask the DJ to play the song
and then I'll just sit at the and I was
like and also I don't know how to sing
or play piano so I'll just do my best to
play along and sing along and she wanted
to play the actual song and while you
pretended ya to be playing and singing I
didn't pretend Conan I tried my best
absolutely zero pretending I was giving
it my heart and soul and and but pink
was her face definitely dropped quite a
bit when I said I needed to sing along
with the recording and you know it then
she was like you know I'll hook it up
hold on a second I mean Oprah was there
it was you know really a night and then
Ellen finally got up on stage and asked
me to please get back down did she
really
Ellen stopped you indeed she did she
thanked me and she was a very nice
gesture but she was like scram kid yeah